all right so this is about W efficient
ZK snarks without trusted setup so zero
knowledge six synched non interactive
argument of knowledge or a ZK snark
these are even the subject of some
intense research interest and more
recently even some interest in the
broader tech world so I'm gonna tell you
about some of the work that my
co-authors and I did but I'm also gonna
try and give you a more general picture
of the area and other systems in it
so first let's let's try to cut a little
bit through the jargon what is ZK snark
well so it's an argument that is it's a
proof but one whose validity depends on
some cryptographic assumption and it's
an argument of knowledge which means you
can use it to prove roughly speaking
that you know a secret and it's zero
knowledge meaning that when you use it
to prove that you know a secret you
don't reveal anything about that secret
M now the proof is six inked meaning
that it's short and it's not interactive
so it can just be written down and then
later somebody can come and read it
it doesn't require any kind of
conversation and finally we're concerned
about publicly verifiable proofs meaning
anyone who reads the proof will be
convinced of its validity so when we
compare these different kinds of snart's
there at least five questions that we
can ask one is how big is the proof we
said it was small six inked but some
kinds of ZK snart's are smaller than
others and generally speaking argument
systems may or may not be succinctly if
you're gonna be sending the proofs over
a network or if you're gonna be storing
many proofs for a long time another
question is how hard is it to generate a
proof that is how much time does it take
to write down the contents of the proof
and relatedly how much time does it take
to check the proof okay and throughout
the talk you're gonna see these a script
P and script V those refer to the prover
and the verifier the entity that
generates the proof and the entity that
checks the proof okay so remember the
validity of these proofs since their
arguments really depend on some
cryptographic assumption so another
question we can ask is what is that
cryptographic assumption we might care
about this because as you would guess
the the cryptographic community has
reason to believe that some assumptions
are better than others maybe because
they've been battle tested for
longer and finally some Z case marks
including the ones that are currently
most widely deployed like in Z cache
require a trusted set up meaning that
somebody has to run an expensive
one-time computation and you can only
believe a proof is valid if you trust
the entity or entities that ran that set
up computation so you can see already
this is a big design space and every
kind of ZK snark and every kind of zero
knowledge proof system more generally
gives some different mix of these
properties so the CK snark my co-authors
and I designed it we call it high rax
and it represents sort of a new point in
the space higher X proves the
satisfiability of arithmetic circuits
will see what in what that means in more
detail soon but for now imagine that we
have some computation see that's a
circuit and that is to say you know sort
of has gates in it we'll get into more
detail on that soon and the prover
convinces the verifier that it knows
some value W which we'll call the
witness that makes the computation or
the circuit output true now for
efficiency higher X requires that the
computation has some kind of repetitive
structure for example it could be many
parallel copies of the same computation
or it could be repeated instances sort
of in series of a computation again
we'll see a little bit more on that
later now in terms of the v costs we
just saw higher access proofs that are
concretely an asymptotically small and
the prover is concretely fast and
asymptotically optimal the verifier is
also fast and it's slightly work saving
which is to say for big enough circuits
the verifier has to do less work to
check the circuit to check the proof
then it would have to to sort of check
the witness itself and and finally hyrax
relies on the discrete log assumption
and it needs no trusted set up so these
are all sort of you know asymptotic
statements or sort of general statements
but you might ask sort of more concrete
more practical questions like how does
it compare to other systems and so
that's what we did we ran several other
snark systems and we sort of did a
concrete comparison and I'll tell you
more about this later but the upshot is
that higher X gives small proofs in the
sense that if you wanted them to be
smaller it seems right now like
have to pay more in terms of prove or
verify or computation or both and hyrax
is fast meaning if you want the prover
or verifier to get faster it seems like
you have to accept bigger proofs so
that's not to say that higher acts is
anything like the best proof system it's
not because there isn't a best one
there's this isn't a competition and
there isn't a winner right this is a
design space and there are different
applications that might use designs in
this space so when you go shopping for a
zero knowledge proof system decide
what's important to you and choose the
correct system the system that matches
up with that the best so that's what
we're gonna do we're gonna start by
taking a look at some of the the design
space of general purpose zero knowledge
proof systems and later we'll look more
at hyraxes design and then some of the
evaluation results I mentioned so when
we talk about general purpose proof
systems usually we mean proof systems
for NP languages so what that means is
there some relation are and we can think
of that as a computation that takes some
values and then returns true or false
now the values are an input X from the
verifier and a witness W from the prover
and we can think of the witness as a
secret that the prover knows and are the
relation as a computation that checks
whether the witness is somehow correct
for the verifiers input and at a very
high level these systems all operate by
turning the witness checking computation
into sort of two different computations
one that's the verifiers job and one
that's the provers job so we can think
of this as sort of happening in two
stages which we'll call the front end
and the back end now in the front end we
convert the witness checking computation
into an arithmetic circuit which is to
say a generalized boolean circuit where
we can think of and gates as becoming
multiplication and or gates as becoming
addition and the front end constructs
this arithmetic circuit such that it's
satisfiability is tantamount to the
correct execution of the witness
checking computation okay then the back
end applies proving machinery which is
some combination of complexity theoretic
and cryptographic objects to produce
approver and a verifier computation such
that a valid
establishes that the circuit is
satisfied which by the implication in
the front end establishes that the
witness checking computation was run
correctly so up to this point I've been
talking about different kinds of zero
knowledge proof systems and and really
what I've been referring to is that that
that proof machinery in the back end so
we're gonna focus in a little bit more
on that let's take a look at how some of
the existing systems work so maybe the
most well-known zero knowledge proof
systems are Pinocchio and Lib snark
these are used for example as I said
earlier in Z cache now these are built
on an object called a linear PCP and
very roughly speaking their properties
are such that they give short proofs and
very fast verification but proving is
slow and they rely on cryptographic
assumptions that are non-standard
that we don't we don't trust them maybe
quite as much and finally they require a
trusted setup somebody has to do that
initial computation now earlier today
you saw a talk by Benedict on bullet
proofs and this realize essentially on a
different kind of linear PCP and some
different crypto and the result is that
bullet proof gives us short proofs and
unlike Lib snark and Pinocchio it uses
standard cryptographic assumptions and
it requires no setup on the other hand
there's a little price and that is that
the the proving in very the especially
the verifying gets a little bit slower
an entirely different class of proof
machinery comes from multi-party
computation in the head which is due to
each eye at all and ZK boo and zk b plus
plus are sort of the first practical
implementations of this paradigm and
they have fast proving they build on a
standard cryptographic assumption and
they have no trusted set up but they
give long proofs and verifying is slow
ish what does that mean well the
asymptotics aren't great so and they
kick in sort of even for moderately
sized problems so for very small
computations these are blindingly fast
but for bigger computations maybe think
again so more recently Leggero improves
on the approach from ZK Buan and ZK be
plus plus and it uses some different
sort of complexity theoretic objects to
give shorter proofs and faster
verification I still say ish here
because compared to libs
Arkan bullet proves the the proofs are
still longer and compared to lip snark
the the verifying is still much slower
okay and finally there's this newest
class of machinery in some sense
building on the oldest class of theory
that it's short PCPs
and Lib Stark is right now the only
practical implementation of this
approach and it gives short proofs and
fast verification and it needs no
trusted setup but proving is slow and it
relies on an unproven conjecture that
has some relation to the hardness of
reed-solomon decoding so this table is
not gospel it's just a rough
approximation of the state of play but
the important thing to get from it is
that there are all these different
systems that you might pick depending on
which of the columns is most important
to you and none of them really is
clearly best on my knees okay so what
that landscape in mind let's take a
quick look at hyraxes machinery so
higher axe is built on a completely
different thing called an interactive
proof which is essentially a
probabilistic cross examination and we
make these interactive proofs is your
knowledge using techniques have been or
at all and Cramer and dam guard but as
we'll see naively applying those
techniques results in poor performance
so in higher X we also include several
refinements which result in order of
magnitudes improvement in both verifier
time and proof size and small constant
factors an improvement for the prover as
well so the high-level idea in higher ax
is that in an interactive proof the
verifier sending questions and the
prover is sending answers to those
questions and what we're gonna do is
replace all the answers that the prover
sends with cryptographic commitments to
the answers and then the prover is going
to help the verifier to check that the
contents of the commitment are actually
a message that would have been valid in
the sort of underlying interactive proof
without revealing anything else um so to
review let's take a look at a
cryptographic commitment so in a
cryptographic commitment scheme we have
a sender that computes a commitment to a
message and then it sends the commitment
to a receiver later that the sender can
open the commitment and then
reveal the message inside and convince
the receiver that the message that's
revealed is consistent with the commute
with the commitment that was sent
earlier so generally speaking commitment
schemes have two properties that we care
about hiding means that the commitment
reveals nothing about the message inside
and binding means that the sender can't
lie when it tries to open the commitment
it can't decide well I really wanted to
send this other message so I'm gonna do
that instead because it'll get caught
cheating so hyrax uses a special class
of commitments that have sort of a third
sorry that have sort of a third property
a linear homomorphism which means
there's some operator that we can use
essentially to add to commitments
together so when we do that we get a new
commitment that has inside of it a
message that's the sum of the two and
from that you can get sort of scaling by
if by some constant factor because you
can just add the same message to itself
many times okay so the other thing that
hyrax builds on is an interactive proof
and specifically one due to Goldwasser
Kauai and Rockland this is an
interactive proof for layered arithmetic
circuit evaluation which means that the
inputs to the circuit feed one set of
gates and those that the outputs from
those gates feed a second set the
outputs from mosby to third etc and so
to start the proof the verifier gives
some inputs to the prover and then the
prover is gonna evaluate the I our
thematic circuit and produce some output
Y that it's gonna send the verifier now
the verifier and the provers start to
interact so first the verifier is going
to construct a polynomial that relates
the purported output that's Y to the
last layer of gates in the circuit then
it's gonna engage the prover in what's
called a sum check protocol this is sort
of a foundational interactive proof and
and the result of that some check
protocol is a claim about the second
last layer of the circuit now in some
sense that's not good enough because the
verifier can't check that very easily so
what are the verifier improver do they
continue to interact so now we run
another some check and we get a claim
about the prior layer and we keep doing
that and eventually we get a claim whose
truth is related to the inputs to the
computation now in a non zero knowledge
version of g'kar this would be it we
would be done because the verifier has
those inputs and it can just check
clean directly but in zero knowledge we
need to make two modifications so the
first one as I said earlier is that the
prover is going to replace all of its
messages in the subject invocations with
commitments to those messages and the
second and this one's a little more
complicated is that we need to give the
verifier some way to check that final
statement in the proof and remember the
verifier never gets to see the witness
and since this is a witness checking
computation somehow the inputs have to
encode the witness
so the verifier certainly can't check
that directly so what's it gonna do well
we're gonna use what we call a a
polynomial commitment scheme so the the
final check that the verifier needs to
do is just evaluating a polynomial that
will call tilde m and this polynomial
encodes both the input and the witness
have to run the check the prover will
send a commitment to the verifier at the
start of the protocol so before any
interaction happens okay then the prover
in the verifier are gonna run the
interactive proof that we just saw on
the previous slide and at the end the
prover is just gonna make a claim it's
gonna say here the evaluation that you
really want is this one is this value
here and finally the prover and verify
are going to engage in an additional
protocol that convinces the verifier
that the output that the prover just
claimed is consistent with the
commitments that the prover sent at the
beginning of the protocol so umm hyrax
uses a new polynomial commitment scheme
for multilinear polynomials which is
what M tilde is and I'm gonna show you a
little bit about how that works now
so these multi linear polynomials have a
specific form namely we can think of
them as a vector matrix vector product
so the vectors l and r depend only on
the point at which we evaluate the
polynomial and the matrix t encodes the
monomials of tilde m in our case the
matrix is encoding w the witness so a
naive approach is that we would just
build a polynomial commitment scheme by
having the prover commit to each element
of the matrix T individually and I think
if you think about it you'll see that
that's enough already
because since the these commitments as I
said earlier have this linear
homomorphism
we can already compute a vector matrix
vector product just by using that
homomorphism okay but that's inefficient
why well the commitment size and the
work to do the polynomial to compute the
commitment so the polynomial is linear
in the size of the witness right so as
the witness gets bigger it scales
linearly and we'd rather scale sub
linearly so to sidestep that problem
we're gonna follow an idea due to yen
scrubbed who uses multi commitment
schemes to commit to each row of the
matrix so what's a multi commitment well
it's a commitment where the message
inside is a vector and if we use the
Petersons commitment then what we get is
a multi commitment that has a vector y's
homomorphism so if we have two
commitments to vectors and we use the
addition operator on them what we get is
a commitment to a new vector that's the
sum vector y's of the previous two okay
so then how are we gonna use this well
the verifier is gonna compute the vector
matrix product L times T by itself using
that vector wise homomorphism and I
think again I think we could see how
that happens the entries of L are each
scaling one row of the matrix T and then
we sum those scaled versions together
and then second the prover is going to
send a commitment to a claimed
evaluation of tilde m and then finally
the prover is going to use what's called
a dot product argument or an inner
product argument to convince the
verifier that the claimed evaluation is
consistent with the vector R and the
vector matrix product L times T that the
verifier previously computed now if this
sounds familiar it's because you've
already seen this earlier today in
bullet proof in fact we adapt the the
dot product argument from bullet proofs
and the result is that this has some
kind of very low cost in terms of the
communication specifically it's
logarithmic in the length in sort of the
number of columns in the matrix so that
means if the matrix is square then the
prover is going to send one commitment
per row plus a logarithmic number of
extra messages that we don't need to
worry too much about they're small and
the verifiers computation is going to be
proportional to the sum of the number of
rows and the number of columns and in
total both of these are just sort of
square root issue okay but alternatively
what we can do is we can
just the size of the matrix we can make
it sort of fewer rows and more columns
and what that means is that the prover
ends up sending less information to the
verifier and then the verifier ends up
having to do a little more work to to
sort of compute over the columns of the
matrix what this means at the at the end
is that you can tailor hyrax to your
applications needs if you need less
communication you can pay for it with a
little bit more verification time
okay so I've described everything in
terms of an interactive proof to get it
non interactive we use the Fiat Jameer
heuristic and we give several other
refinements that I'll leave to the paper
but I'll just mention them quickly here
first we also use these multi
commitments to save proof size and
verify our work in the sum check
invocations a second we develop what we
call a redistribution layer which
remember I said we need some sort of
repeated structure to the computation
the point of the redistribution layer is
to sort of give us a wider range of
computations that we can turn into
something that has the appropriate
repeated structure and finally we
tweaked the giraffe interactive proof
which is prior work to make giraffe plus
plus which reduces the proof size
somewhat further ok so let's take a look
at the evaluation results so our points
of comparison are five existing systems
that it's BCC GP square root bullet
proofs z kb plus plus li hero lib stark
and then also two versions of hyrax
one where the matrix t has sort of twice
as many columns as rows and we use the
polynomial commitment scheme trick that
i described earlier and the other where
we leave off all the refinements we just
do them the naive straightforward thing
so the idea there is let's see how much
those refinements help and don't worry
too much about memorizing the legend
I'll repeat it on the next slides I
promise um so we compare these systems
at 90 bit security which arguably is too
low but maybe is sort of the starting
point for what you might use for a
non-interactive proof and the benchmark
I'm going to show you is what's called a
shot 256 Merkel tree so in this
benchmark the prover is going to
convince the verifier that it knows all
the leaves of a hash tree that
correspond to a root at the verifier
holds okay so first up is proof size
versus log of the number
in the hash tree so both x and y-axes
are effectively logarithmic and the
green dots are hyrax
so remember hyrax lets you tailor the
proof size in the verifier time and as I
said earlier we tailored it to sort of a
short fat matrix so what I'm showing you
here I hire X 1/3 and the result of that
sort of tailoring is that the higher X
has kind of the second-best proof size
among these systems but you can see that
bullet proof has much much better proof
size much smaller and on the other side
ZK boo the red squares has these very
large proofs and the naive version of
hyrax where we don't apply any of the
optimizations is even worse right it's
huge huge fruit okay but what that means
is in some sense the refinements are
working already
right we can see that they improve the
proof size next up is approver time
again this is log log scale and remember
zkb + + remember you'll see it had the
biggest proofs but now it also has the
fastest prover right so if you need a
screaming fast prove er you choose ZK be
like heroes prove er it also has a has a
good showing and then hire X is kind of
next up and what you see is that whereas
bullet proofs had sort of a very small
proof you pay for that by having to sort
of work harder to generate that proof
right and this is sort of a theme that
we'll see a couple more times and
finally you can see there's son of a
small constant factor maybe 3 X between
the blue stars that's the unrefined
version of higher x and the green
diamond there are the green hexes the
refined version finally let's look at
the verifier time so here Lib Stark has
far and away the best performance and
hero again very good performance and
speed um for big enough problems hyrax
is faster than z kv + + so remember what
i said the the verifier in zk b is kind
of slow ish or fast ish depending on
anyway think about it because once the
problem gets big enough then the
verifier time starts to run away and
finally this is another case where the
improvements from from higher ax the the
difference between the blue stars and
the green hexes is really big so those
refinements are really help in terms of
the verifier time ok so let's conclude
I've showed you hyrax which is sort
new general purposes DK snark and as we
saw hi Rex gives you kind of small
proofs in the sense that if you want
them to be smaller you've got to use a
system with more prove err and verifier
cost and it's fast in the sense that if
you want faster you have to pay with for
that a bigger proofs but again the most
important takeaway here is that there's
no real winner because there's no actual
competition different proof systems give
different combinations of properties and
what we should be doing is thinking
about our application carefully and then
choosing the one that applies so higher
acts from that point of view is just a
point in the design space and of course
there are other points in the design
space that are even better that we
haven't reached yet so there's plenty
more work to do our paper and our code
are available online and I hope you'll
check them out and with that I'll take
any questions I think we should hope for
it in the sense that like it would make
our lives easy we just run that proof
system and be done and then everyone
could concentrate on on improving it and
making a nice implementation but you
know it's slightly I think for now
magical to hope for it in the sense that
everyone is using certain tricks to get
their good points and in the in the end
that's what's producing their bad points
[Applause]
you